let's see the answers buy more powerful
hardware yes that could certainly help
but he will not provide unlimited
scalability what about optimizing the
software yes that could certainly also
help but that will not provide unlimited
scalability either copy and run software
on more servers well normally software
cannot just be copied and run on more
servers to be able to run on more
servers you typically have to change the
software so this option is also an
alternative in fact if you can change
your software to run on more servers you
are starting to work with the scalable
architecture this is because the
capacity will not be limited by the
hardware you use or how much you can
optimize your software when you need to
scale you can add more servers